hi Matt here are you looking for another
great podcast our friends at Harvard
Business Review have a podcast you might
like hbr ideacast every Tuesday they
bring you the world's best business and
Leadership experts to help you manage up
manage a business and manage yourself
I'm a big fan of their recent episode
where a marketing professor and a
Matchmaker talk personal branding listen
to hbr ideacast for free wherever you
get your podcasts it's all you need to
lead
people actually follow recommendations
more when they're said than when they're
written
[Music]
reason research has shown that sharing
gold failure stories as a leader
actually made you a more influential
leader
we can get a little bit too obsessed
with driving towards the destination and
we have lots of tools for making that as
efficient as possible
[Music]
to somebody who has facilitated the
engagement going early to the engagement
or the room and walking around and
chatting with people so you have an idea
of where people are and what they are
most interested in learning so that you
can deliver so know your audience
foreign
what do you get when you bring together
400 students from all over the world
four professors who are insightful and
inviting and one mediocre podcast host
you get an amazing educational
experience welcome to think fast talk
smart the podcast I'm Matt Abrahams and
I teach strategic communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business
recently we did our first ever live
in-person podcast session we brought
Stanford lead students from all over the
world in to chat with four of our
previous guests yes for Sorensen Suchi
Huang Sarah Sewell and Jonathan Laval
what you're about to listen to is a
condensed version of that conversation
we'll start by hearing from everybody
expand on some of the things we've
discussed in previous podcast episodes
and then I'll ask our guests to share
something their research searching that
excites them and then have some closing
advice along with some listener
questions enjoy
foreign
I am thrilled to be here with all of you
thank you so much for the support of our
podcast and we love getting your
questions your feedback your your
following on LinkedIn and Instagram
thank you so much we wanted today to be
very special so we've invited four of
our most popular guests to come talk
with us so we're going to have fun and
we look forward to hearing from you so
let's get into it yes sir we're going to
start with you for those of you who
don't know yes spur Jesper is a
professor in organizational behavior and
the senior associate dean of academic
Affairs when Jesper and I had our
conversation on the podcast he shared
how when we think about strategy we can
think about strategy as making an
argument telling a story and it turned
out to be one of our most popular
episodes on YouTube people really really
got interested in in strategy and how to
tell strategy stories and make Arguments
for your strategy so yes sir my question
to you is for all of us we all have our
own personal strategies our our goals
for ourselves can you you give us some
suggestions about how we can tell our
own strategy stories sure so I mean
thanks first of all for for having all
of us here and for doing this and for
this amazing crowd uh and I I'm
continually Amazed by the fact that the
YouTube video is so popular but I think
it's because we didn't actually video
record I have a face for podcasts I
think it's what somebody's talking about
so yeah so when I talk about strategy I
think about strategy as being the
narrative right that you have for why it
is you're able to accomplish what it is
you do and I think you can think about
that in in different kinds of ways as
you think about constructing these
stories for yourself and that's whether
you're constructing that story for your
company or for your own career I think
for me the most important thing to
remember is that unless a story is
fictional you have to give yourself a
little bit of uh space and some
forgiveness for not having the story
right at any given point in time I think
when you think about when people think
about their careers right you see young
people just starting out they have this
idea that they should have a very clear
trajectory and plan and so on and so
forth and then they get very anxious and
frustrated sometimes when things don't
work out the way that they want it
because it doesn't fit that narrative
that they had constructed for themselves
but again I think the only stories you
can tell in advance are fictional and so
that means that that story was a fiction
right and that the story is going to be
the one that evolves and I think when
you get to be as old as some of us are
up at this panel right you realize that
really it's about things that you
discover as you go along the way and so
I think where this matters the most is
when you're making big decisions and I
think the thing that I like to think
about is you should always think about a
decision where you think about an
experiment as being something where
you're testing hypothesis you're testing
a theory and in particular you should
think about what you learn from that
experiment as being something that
informs your understanding of what your
story is going to be and how it's going
to evolve so I think Jesper called me
old I think I just thought I was
referring to myself I see okay I I
appreciate very much the the notion of
running those experiments and then
figuring out how to communicate them and
what I also really heard which is
important for me personally is to remind
myself to give myself a little space and
Grace as I think through those things
it's very easy to get caught up in the
moment and not give yourself that space
so thank you for that next I'd like to
come to Sushi's Sushi is an associate
professor in marketing and her research
focuses on consumer motivation and when
tsuchi joined us we talked a lot about
motivation and one of the things that I
really took away from our podcast
together was how to sustain motivation
over time and in fact after that episode
I told some of my friends about what we
had talked about and we all agreed that
we're going to take on this new type of
exercise that we hadn't done before and
we we were a little competitive but
we're mostly supportive in what I took
away from the episode is when I should
best compare myself to my colleagues and
how that can help sustain that
motivation all of us in this room are
endeavoring to lots of different things
Suchi can you share with us some ways to
sustain that motivation in the
activities that we all do sure
definitely and first of all I'm glad to
hear that you took my advice I do it's
actually using it so I have three things
to share with you today first start
small second social support and third
Journey mindset so first start small a
lot of us have thin goals and definitely
for your organization the goal is big
the big goals means it's valuable and
it's not attainable and it is really
hard to get motivated when we only focus
on bingo so we are starting it's really
important to focus on slow goals you
make it into piecemeal goals instead of
thinking about a large quarterly or
annual goals what should we achieve by
the end of today so when you start small
it's easier to motivate yourself as a
leader and also to motivate your
employees and stakeholders second social
support I see that that's what Matt took
to heart we in our research we found
that social support fluctuate in the
beginning we are excited to actually
announce that our goal get everybody on
board we're getting close to the end of
the quarter or the year we are also
excited because we will not celebrate
and we think we are winning it is
through the middle stage that things get
muddy when you feel especially
challenged that's when we hide from
social information we don't want to know
what our peers are doing because those
information is threatening but what we
found is that at those very moments is
exactly when you need social information
and social support to get you going
either to give you some competitive
motivation or some collaborative energy
so social support is important
throughout and especially in the middle
when things get tough the last thing is
Journey mindset in a society today we
think about goals as destination which
is great we are motivated to reach them
and we have no clue what to do after we
reach them thinking about goal as a
journey means that it's not just about
reaching the goal and get it done it's
about also thinking about that as a
continuation after I reach this goal
there's the next thing I look back and
think about what went right and what
went wrong and I take what I learned and
I continue so it is a continuous journey
in never really and that is really
helpful for maintain attending that
motivation absolutely and I and I see
how what you just said about the journey
mindset ties nicely to what yes per said
about running experiments so if you're
continually thinking about the next step
is another experiment that all of a
sudden starts helping you define that
narrative and can help you figure out
where you want to go next so thank you
for that I'd like to come next to Sarah
Sarah is a professor of organizational
behavior I recently came to learn about
some of your new research that you
published and it's about confessions and
fessing up to misdeeds and misbehaviors
and wondering if you can share a bit
about what you found and any advice that
it leads to absolutely let me tell you
about this research in 2020 I'll take
you back to that year when in May of
that month in the United States a man by
the name of George Floyd was killed by
police in Minneapolis now what you may
have noticed either here in the U.S or
in your own whole country was that many
leaders of organizations CEOs
organizational leaders of educational
institutions and non-profits and so on
issued racial Justice states in the wake
of that event sometimes these statements
issued support for the black lives
matter movement sometimes they issued
support for any kinds of isn't
procedures within the organization to do
something about racial and inequity in
the organization or abroad and so on and
we remember I say we I mean my wonderful
PhD student Lambert Me took notice of
this and decided to collect all of these
statements from Fortune 500 companies as
well as benefit corporations and we
noticed a pattern which was surprising
to us and that is that many leaders
willingly confess and that's the term we
use issued a public confession about
either not knowing that there was a
problem with racial inequity in the
country even confessing publicly that
they were complicit in some way we found
interested because much of the prior
literature which is known as impression
management talks about ways in which
corporate leaders when communicating put
positive information out here we saw
something different a willingness to put
forth negative information about
themselves and so what we did with these
statements one of the first things we've
done with these statements is sent them
out all of them we collected 525 of
these statements and we sent them out to
people in an online survey and asked
them to tell us what they think about
the leader and about the state unit cell
and what they think about the
organization in terms of their Corporate
social responsibility and their
reputation for corporate social
responsibility we found that in the
statements not all of them had a
confession but those statements which
did have a confession were associated
with positive views of the leader and an
impression that that organization was a
good Corporate social responsible actor
and it was especially true but for any
kind of concession but for those can
confessions that involved confessing
something negative they have done we
call this a confession of commitment
right those were especially highly rated
so in terms of thinking about what this
might mean I think importantly what
we're seeing at least with the case of
racial Justice in the U.S was that there
was something different happening with
impression management rather than
putting positive information out there
the The View that the leader in the
organization is authentic and
transparent was what led to more
favorable towards the organization and
especially towards the organization as a
responsible in society so it's changing
the common perception that you only put
out positive information by
acknowledging some negative behavior it
actually has some positive benefits well
now I'm coming to Jonathan Jonathan lab
a professor of marketing the only
podcast guest ever to swear in an
episode our editor had to work extra
time on that one Jonathan you have some
research out about giving
recommendations and there's a difference
between speaking those recommendations
versus actually having them in writing
can you share a little bit about the
results of that study and what it might
mean for us as we get recommendations I
promise to keep it clean because there's
no editing I don't even remember right
cursed I thought it was a natural course
event in general my research is kind of
looks at the difference in sort of
physical experiences of consuming
technology and so how those different
ways in which we consume technology
influence our decision-making process
and so one of the things that we've
looked at is modalities and so what
technologies allow you to do is that
allow you to present information in
different modalities so you can read
things and sometimes you can feel things
and you can also hear them or say them
out loud and so it turns out that you
would think that whether you read
something or hear something it should
have the same effect because after all
it's the same information if I tell you
you should take Sarah sewell's class
right whether I wrote take Sarah
sewell's class or and I said take Sarah
Soul's class but it should be the same
the recommendation is the same but what
we're finding is that people actually
follow recommendations more when they're
said that when they're written and the
effect is a large but it's very
consistent and we look at it across lots
of different both consumer products and
also different kinds of tasks and it's a
little bit of a mystery to us why
exactly it's happening what we're
finding is that it has to do with the
ephemerality of the information when I
say something it's gone when something
is written it's still in front of me oh
we're finding is that when people are
exposed to ephemeral information we also
test that by actually showing them
sentences of things that go and
disappear right so we can create
ephemerality also with written text
because it basically creates almost like
an action orientation like to be able to
hang on to that information I have to
create I have to act on it and so that
translates into when you hear a
recommendation right you say okay I'm
going to follow it whereas when you read
it you don't have to sort of engage in
that kind of immediate action moment and
so we find that with a couple of
actually I should credit the grad
students schweta maridaso and Chris
Beckler who co-authored this with me
perhaps one of the reasons the podcast
has been successful is it's us making
recommendations in the spoken format so
so maybe we're on to something also
you're a celeb Matt oh yeah right
exactly now let's hear from Jesper and
Jonathan as they describe some of their
current research and thinking
[Music]
I'm very interested I have been for a
while on entrepreneurship and for a long
time what I studied was why do people
choose to leave their jobs to become
entrepreneurs and one of the things that
I've emphasized way in which
entrepreneurship we should think about
entrepreneurship as being part of a
career as opposed to the way we tend to
think about it in the scholarly
literature is we kind of like you become
an entrepreneur and then we stop
entrepreneurship is actually more like
marriage right like you enter into it
and then sometimes it works and
sometimes it doesn't mindfully like
entrepreneurship has a higher failure
rate than marriage well what that means
is that there that a lot of people try
this right in various kinds of ways and
then they have to find jobs so what I'm
interested in now is like how do
employers respond to somebody who
applies for a job and who has
entrepreneurial experience on their
resume when there is some existing
research that shows that if you send
people resumes with you know two resumes
one that has entrepreneurial experience
on it and the other one that doesn't the
person who has the entrepreneurial
experience is actually less likely to
get a callback which is puzzling right
so there's kind of a penalty and so
there are various theories about that
about well entrepreneurs are hard to
manage they're hard to control and that
to me feels like a very ad hoc post-hoc
argument so we're trying to figure out
what the real story is intuition right
now is that there's two stages in a
hiring process there's a screening stage
where people are just kind of going
through all the resumes and trying to
figure out the ones they're going to pay
more attention to and then there's a
more deep evaluations what happens is at
the screening stage you don't really pay
attention to ones that don't fit into
your mental model so if you're looking
for a marketing manager you want
somebody kind of has work experience as
a marketing manager and if you see that
they had their own startup doing
marketing stuff you're like you know in
your kind of mind kind of shuts that out
and so but if you get to the evaluation
stage maybe you have a more well-rounded
assessment of what actually the
strengths and weaknesses of an
entrepreneur because entrepreneurs are
also creative they're energetic they are
go-getters and so forth so you would
think that employers would want those
candidate dates as well so the so watch
is partially around thinking about how
employers process things and then
there's also going to be a set of
implications for how you might think
about that as an entrepreneur about how
you want to portray your accomplishments
absolutely what you put on that resume
on LinkedIn might affect how people
think about you for sure and I like that
yes per use that analogy to marriage one
of the things that comes up a lot on the
podcast is how we frame things Michelle
gelfin spends some time talking about
how you frame negotiation how you frame
entrepreneurship framing really affects
the way that you yourself perceive what
you're talking about but also how others
you interact so thank you for
demonstrating that Jonathan let me come
to you what are you studying or doing
I'll talk about something that we're
just we don't know the results we don't
know if it's going to work and we'll be
running the experiment now so one of the
issues that I've developed is is in
face-to-face versus video interactions
and and we did a bunch of research on it
that looked at sort of creative output
and video versus face-to-face you do
better Face to Face by the way just as a
quickie just so you know but sort of
that sort of gave rise to a whole set of
other interests and one of the things
that is different in video interaction
is a psychological distance when you're
talking to somebody on video there's
some kind of sense of distance I have a
grad student that was talking about
working with one of our colleagues and
he said I could never work with him if
it was face to face he's too aggressive
for me but online I can totally do it
and we're like all right let's test it
so now we'll actually running a study it
takes quite a while but um we're running
a study we're using an economic game
where you can basically be aggressive
towards somebody else by taking warm the
pot and we're looking to see are there
differences well when people are playing
this game face to face versus over video
and then we also measure a series of
things of sort of how they feel about
each other afterwards I don't have the
results yet that's the latest I think
it's fascinating to think about how
being virtual affects everything about
how we feel about people what we're
willing to say and do and I think that
research sounds really interesting
foreign
we took a break from the academic
conversation and looked to get questions
from our audience hi I'm Felicia
cameriani I'm curious Professor Seoul if
you can comment on in social media we
have seen so many people forthright
about confessions and wrongdoing in the
cancel culture really good question here
and I'm going to say that one of the
things that we haven't tested and I'm
not sure how to test is where this idea
of public confessions came from and I
suspect that this came from the metoo
movement where we saw a lot of male
leaders in particular proactively
getting ahead of the curve and
confessing before an accusation came
forward and so I suspect that this might
have been a kind of a diffusion process
by which other corporate leaders decided
and again with the racial justice issue
to do this before discoverable
information came forward and they were
directly targeted so I in terms of you
know thing talking about cancel culture
and so on I suspect that this is exactly
a proactive a defensive mechanism prior
to the possibility of being quote
unquote canceled my name is Sangeeta I'm
from Bay Area another part topic that we
had today is AI my question to panel is
how do you see this AI impacting
Humanity overall so I'll start and I
would love to hear from some of you I
interviewed chat GPT I don't know if you
heard that it was it was it was actually
cool but scary at the same time so I
typed in questions and then we did a a
text to voice response and it was really
fascinating to have it tell me that I
one could keep my job which made me feel
really good but also that for it to
explain that it understands that there
are ethical and information biases that
it could have and that to me is
something to think about now as a
teacher I do see value in some of what
it can provide it gives my students for
example opportunities to practice you
can type in generate questions about X
and then they can practice answering
those questions in a way that they
couldn't prior so for me personally I'm
still trying to figure it out but I see
that there are advantages to learning
but there are also some concerns yeah so
I have a variety of reactions to these
things so I would say first of all as a
teacher you always worry about how it's
going to make your life harder and uh
because it's making grading a lot harder
but I think that's probably a good thing
because now we have to think more
carefully about and you know what we
know is that there's always moral panics
right about these things so when I was a
kid it was all about calculators people
would never be able to do math again and
that might be true right actually but we
are still around I mean to me what's
interesting about these kinds of things
like child CPT is we worry about them
supplanting us I guess but like I think
what we have to remember is that
everything that is able to do is based
on trying to recombine everything that's
already existed and so that's a limited
form of creativity it's a very important
form of creativity and production
certainly and so I can see places where
that's going to matter a lot but I think
there's also at the same time lots of
room for us maybe free us up to do other
things my name is
a follow-up question have you figured
out how you are going to figure identify
whether the essay is chat gptsa versus a
genuine essay this is a really terrific
question and I have one anecdote was a
colleague in another at another
University was concerned about students
writing their essays for the final exam
rather than giving them the question to
answer they probably had chat GPT answer
it and then the student's assignment was
to critique what chat GPT had come up
with by citing material in the class and
so on so there are really nice and
creative ways to lean into what chat GPT
is doing and also I think that there are
some nuances that we can pick up on even
if we think we can
family white huge fan of yours as you
know um I listened to your podcast a lot
and share it with with everyone so my
question is as um as an educator this
down with GSB what's your biggest
communication challenge for me
personally it's just getting my students
attention Stanford MBA students and our
MSX students and others are they're so
amazing and they're so busy and they're
doing so much it's just
helping to give them space to to work on
the things that we work on and it's it
there's just so much going on so for me
personally it's trying to create
activities and experiences that are
immersive enough to get that Focus so
that the work can be done and that's not
I'm not saying anything negative about
them the work that they're doing is
phenomenal and I learned so much from my
students it's just getting the the Mind
share in the moment in the class to do
that I think my biggest challenge with
efforts came to Stanford which was 10
years ago was to learn how to project
competence in this environment so I grew
up in Asia and I say Asian female
automatically I might the perception of
me that I'm warm approachable but maybe
less confident and I have to learn how
to actually understand that he will
leverage that queue starting from
wearing high heels to learning how to
project my voice and eventually learning
how to actually communicate that through
my content as well I think that was my
biggest challenge I will just add I
think the biggest challenge right now
with Communications is what the panda
has done to all of us but especially
some of our Learners and part of that I
think is getting the attention but I
think part of it's also that you know
many people are suffering and most
people I will argue are suffering some
of the after effects of the pandemic and
being able to be empathetic to what
people are going through and
understanding where we can push and
where we shouldn't push it
[Music]
before we wrapped up our event I asked
several of our panelists for closing
advice that they had for anyone wishing
to hone their leadership skills spend
just a moment to share perhaps a bit of
advice for our awesome leaders in the
room maybe short-term advice about what
to do while here on campus or maybe
longer term advice in terms of what
they're doing as their careers unfold
why don't we start with Suchi so I'm one
of the vice since I study goal and
motivation share your failure you talk a
lot about our goal of success but
research has reason research has shown
that sharing goal failure stories as a
leader actually made you a more
influential leader and it doesn't
actually hurt the perception of your
ability they only make you actually
better connect feel free to share gold
failure first let me say thank you Suchi
I want to talk more about that because
that seems like perhaps some of the
mechanism in the public confession and
my advice actually comes from Matt so
I've had the opportunity to each with
Matt and also to watch Matt teach and
listen to his advice and one of the
things that Matt always tells us is to
know your audience so in your
communication figure out how to learn
who it is that you are about to address
whether that is by reading about them on
LinkedIn talking to somebody who has
facilitated the engagement going early
to the engagement or the room and
walking around and chatting with people
so you have an idea of where people are
and what they're most interested in
learning so that you can deliver so know
your audience in your communication I
guess what I would say is you know I
think it's very important to have a
sense of goals and a sense of purpose I
don't think we should be so wedded to
that we are not open something that has
been lost with new technologies if you
think about Google Maps right so now you
go to a new city and you're like okay I
want to go visit this Cathedral and you
get on your phone and says okay Walk
This Way and again in the old days I'm
sounding a lot like moment but like you
would like get out a map and you would
try to read and you're like start
walking and then suddenly you'd end up
in a totally different place and that
would be spectacular you would
eventually make it to the cathedral or
whatever but it's actually this place
you ended up at by mistake that was much
more powerful and I think we can get a
little bit too obsessed with driving
towards the destination and we have lots
of tools for making that as efficient as
possible and we don't want to lose sight
of all the fact that the great things
that come from being open to new
discovery as a special treat we asked
some of the audience members to share
their answers to the questions I end
every episode with okay my name is so
the question that I've got was what's
the best advice you have received when
it comes to communicating with others
and I don't know if that's the best
advice but it's one of the most
difficult ones for me so it's kind of a
question which which is around think
about the most important thing that you
want the audience to remember or to
understand after you communicate with
them of course the communicated admirer
have to mention Matt because he's so
smooth as silk and Flawless with no
fillers but recently I saw the
presentation of Brian chesky CEO of
Airbnb I found him to be very riveting
very energetic and he was able to
condiment a lot of his accounts with
storytelling so I found him to be very
effective as a communicator
hello I'm Stefania and the three
ingredients first one for a successful
communication would be knowing that your
audience because this is a very
important thing to know in tailoring
your message second structure putting
structure will help your audience follow
your message and the third one will be
Clarity like avoiding misunderstandings
misinterpretations
there you have it our first ever
in-person live podcast episode a big
thank you to all of the people in the
audience who participated and to my
guests yes for Sorensen Sarah Sewell
Suchi Huang and Jonathan Laval I hope
you took away some interesting insights
and some valuable lessons to help you be
a better leader and a better
communicator
think fast talk smart the podcast is a
production of Stanford Graduate School
of Business this episode was produced by
Podium podcast company Jenny Luna and me
Matt Abrahams
find more resources follow and join our
conversation on LinkedIn by searching
think fast talk smart